hey everyone welcome back to the
corridor cast today at the table we are
joined by Niko Clinton Jones and Daniel
D Kim from the node channel so thanks to
him for being here as well and we wanted
to do something a little bit different
today most of the time when it's just
the guys on the table here we'd like to
talk about things in the news world
events things that are going on and sort
of just have fun and give our take and
our input on it but today we wanted to
do something a little bit more personal
you see each time before we do one of
these episodes I'll go in and I'll I'll
scroll through all the current events
that are happening and I'll track them
sort of throughout the week leading up
to when we record and I was just a
little bit overwhelmed by the amount of
negative and deconstructive things that
are going on in the world right now and
and I wanted to take this podcast and
say instead of talking about that stuff
let's just get away from it for an hour
and let's just have some fun and let's
just tell some personal stories and get
to know each other a little bit better
and so that's exactly what we did here
today and I hope you guys enjoy it if
you'd like to see more like this
definitely let us know we'll definitely
be doing all kinds of different formats
here as time goes by and yeah enjoy I
also wanted to let you know that today's
sponsor is story box once again they are
our flagship sponsor so far and they've
been awesome so I'll tell you guys more
about that and why they're your one-stop
shop for all your stock video needs
later in the episode hello guys welcome
back to the corridor cast we're so glad
you're here alright so for those of you
who aren't in the know which is actually
most people because I tend not to get
too much my personal life out on the
Internet I'm having a baby next week
well I'm not having the baby my wife is
having don't take all the credit
yes and you know usually it's a decision
to have a baby sometimes it's an
accident but in this case it was a
decision and you know I was reflecting a
little bit upon the things that led me
to have the decision to decide to try to
have a kid you know cuz like I'd come
home I'd go through my routine you know
I play my drums play some video games
do my thing and hang out with friends
and like after doing that for a couple
years I started kind of those two things
that kind of happened when you hit your
30s
one is the possibilities and potential
of the world says to crystallize for you
in the sense that you know when you're
18 years old you could be anything you
might you might pull it off you might be
a race car driver you might be an
astronaut you might be a filmmaker you
know you know quite know what's gonna
happen and anything is possible
once you hit 30 and I'm 33 what you are
going to be is starting to solidify if
it hasn't already I mean things can
still change but you're definitely
starting to move past some errors in
your life and you start seeking a sense
of you know word is your fulfillment lie
and so I was kind of thinking back to
like where I was in high school and like
what I thought was important in life you
know what did I want to do and you know
today we're you know we're joined by
Diaz well yeah yeah hey Sam's out in
Minnesota on vacation Wren is out in
Oregon Oregon Oregon Oregon E that's
people you can tell someone's not from
Oregon if they call it Oregon yep and so
I can't wanted to ask you guys you know
like looking back at your time in high
school what was important to you like
what did you see yourself wanting in
life to be happy and now that you are
effectively twice the age not quite
twice the age that you were in high
school you're looking back look look
back at those things that you thought
would make you happy and do you find
that that's still true like did your
perspective you have on life in high
school like hold throughout all these
years because all those things are the
things that motivate you to even get
where you're going like I want to get
into filmmaking when I was in high
school guess what Here I am you know I
still like doing it I
by-and-large I'd say only about half of
what I thought in high school was true
what had said it was important to you
and I said what I thought well see I
really like I really thought that and
this is interesting because the guy that
was recently on Joe Rogan that Eric
Weinstein Eric Weinstein guy who's like
a mathematician was talking about this
and he's talking about how there's all
these portals in life that introduced us
to worlds of the unknown and stuff like
that and I was obsessed with that stuff
in high school like I was all about
portals in the sense of like
philosophies unique things in
mathematics and in logic and in science
that that hint at you know the the the
other dimensions of the world and of the
universe figure dimensions don't make
your dues my philosophical mathematical
you mean like opportunities or you mean
literal dimensions like literal
dimensions things that things that in
things that effect are obviously there's
more than one dimension right like yeah
that's I think pretty well accepted but
when those went into like
interdimensional portals is the stuff
that he kept talking about and you can
see these things and certain types of
logic and in certain types of types of
mathematics and I was obsessed with
finding those things when I was when I
was younger I was obsessed with like
understanding what like the best
philosophy was and what the best
religion was and like what the best
things that told you about God and told
you about truth and told you about the
universe were and that was very good at
that time but as I got older the more
that I learned about those things the
more I real like it's a catch-22 because
the more you learn about those things
the more you realize you know nothing
about those things and so at the time I
thought there's a there's a hard truth
to all this there's like there's
something at the end of the of the
tunnel that will tell me about truth and
and all of that stuff and the the more
that I studied that and thought about it
and looked it looked for it the more
that I realized that that's not true the
more that I realized that you need to
come to that on your own as an
individual and that that there is truth
I fully believe that but but that there
is it is
your truth and that that that relates to
other people but it is relative in that
sense like you know what that makes me
think that that sounds like the origin
of like the origin place of FOMO fear of
missing out just like needing to know
like what is the best right and I think
yeah with the internet we have a lot
more access to you know it's like what's
the best toothbrush well I can look up
what the best really and back then yeah
I I did the same thing he spent a lot of
time thinking like yeah to make sure you
don't you know especially the religion
when you're younger right yeah so yeah I
have here on that sure it's very
formative and I was glad to have done it
and I am more settled now and sort of
like what I believe and like Who I am
and and all that stuff
but yeah I think that's certainly
changed there's maybe and I don't mean
this in like a negative sense but like a
sense of arrogance that comes into
looking for the best way of do something
doing something in the best way of like
finding that truth because I think
another thing that happens as you get
older is you such realize that it
doesn't really matter all that much to
the rest of the world what you've
discovered like you know yourself matter
yourself yeah of course but you know
even then at a certain point like to
what extent does that even matter to
yourself like because there's an ending
point to where you're going and if it's
not going to carry on past that does it
matter so much if you have a different
perspective you know but I think in the
bigger pictures like it doesn't really
help the world explicitly for you to
find a better religion for yourself per
se yeah I think the idea is just that
you don't want to question your choices
when you get older you don't want to
feel like what if I did this or what if
I did that I think it's more of an idea
of just like it doesn't really affect
the world I agree but I think just being
an old man and not living with a ton of
regret or like Oh questions like how
what if I live my life this way I think
that's like I think for me personally
that's the most important thing is I
guess why I want to try so many
different things and
don't try to be a good person like at
least that and yeah that was the
motivating force for me to is that I
wanted to make sure I didn't want to
have regrets about that stuff when I got
older so I spend a lot of time thinking
about it when I was younger I was glad I
did it helped for me
Who I am and I don't mean to say like
there's no truth or people can believe
whatever they want because there's there
certainly is a reality to the universe
and I think it does affect the world in
the sense that if you discover who you
are as a person yourself you also can
then turn around and more benefit or
benefit to the world around you yes
opposed yeah that's I guess I could see
that fact just a sense of what's in I
mean this has what importance what is
important it changes over time
you know both to yourself and to what's
around you and what the world needs
around you as well yeah yeah that was a
lot deeper than answers going deep was
like interesting so there was a two-part
right it was a two-part you said where
did you see yourself when you're in high
school mmm like where you are now like
is it lineup or reality did you want to
do something else that you want to be
something else like your potential has
crystallized by this point to a certain
extent you know do you feel do you feel
locked in like and you don't want to be
here or the path that you set yourself
on like are you happy with where you've
ended up and does like no what I thought
would make me happy back in high school
Here I am now having implemented all
those things I'm speaking figuratively
for like all of us you're like do you do
you feel like that was the case like did
you did you pursue what you thought
would make you happy back then and did
it work out you got me this yes I didn't
you yeah I did I wanted to well dude for
the longest time I wanted to be in the
Marines and I signed up for the Marines
and right at the last minute I bailed
because I knew that I wanted to like be
a creative and I mean I was I was
so since I was three I was drawing stuff
and creating stuff and coloring and all
that good why'd you bail because I I
wanted to pursue film I wanted to pursue
I wanted to make a movie I wanted to
make sure it's I wanted to do VFX like I
wanted to be more creative than make you
a question because I'm asking you
because I asked myself the same question
cuz a very similar situation did you
bail because you thought you realized
that you were joining the military for
the wrong reason because that's why I
bailed yeah there was there was some
thought on that cause like it wasn't the
thing where it was like join the
military because I've no other choice
like cuz I was like everybody's well I'm
bored like it wasn't one of those
situations there's there's that well
yeah there's other reasons why cuz I
guess what your reason was to and
Wednesday yeah yeah so I mean I I don't
know dude like I grew up around friends
whose dads were in the Marines and like
we dressed up in camo and ran around the
neighbourhood and hit yelling I walked
around the neighborhood with a log
strapped on my back and pretended it was
a bazooka oh yeah
days yeah like all that stuff man like
we built one of my on one of my
birthday's we built like a camo tent we
went with 6:00 in the morning me my
friend Nick and we built this like camo
tent outside and it was like as the Sun
was coming up and we just like we're
like I literally built binoculars out of
212 paper rolls it was like cars like
passing by and just like on on watch in
my neighborhood and I was like yeah it's
funny so ladies can go back in your bed
at night yeah yeah player PlayStation
Clinton killed his first man when he was
seven yeah but yeah I don't know I was
like well no I'm having so much fun
making shorts and being creative you
know but I still have that urge to like
want to serve you know like I want to do
something like I always go back to like
what am I even doing making videos like
how is this helping the greater cause of
everything and like really Oh people are
sad you can make them happy with your
videos yeah I guess but like I also
wanted to be a fireman to like I really
want to like I don't know
like that I love a challenge like that's
that's what I love is a challenge
creators challenge sure yeah it's
interesting what you said dia about the
people playing soldier feel like there's
a lot of that going around man oh yeah I
got a lot of people waking up going hey
the world should be like this and then
it's getting getting feisty about it but
then as soon as they get hungry or they
get tired or whatever or their Wi-Fi
doesn't work yeah they go back to do
whatever the heck it is they were doing
before and that's kind of I was I was
kind of like that that's why when I was
you know discovering who I was back in
the day like I was kind of like the
world should be like this and we should
all do this and you know I had all these
philosophies on how that should be but I
was exactly that I got to go back every
day and sleep in a bed and go to this
really nice get this really nice
education and do all this stuff that you
know was all yeah it was ultimately a
privilege of the world that I wanted to
that I thought could be better you know
yeah I mean generally the best things in
the world come with the most risk
generally yeah I'm like falling in love
you know serving in the military having
those like great experiences but same
time you risk your life it's like a it's
like a really good video game like the
best video games are the ones that
require commitment and time you put into
it the more time in committee you put
into it the more you get out of it at
least that's how I feel as opposed to
just like I'm gonna jump in this arcade
shooter and Killah hope people die oh
well I'm gonna forget about that round
in three seconds you taking a dig at
Smash Brothers battle royale games are
like dayz stuff like that yeah it just
in terms of like more commits you put
into it obviously the more invested
you're gonna be in that experience so
yeah you saw you said you're potentially
going to join the military what branch
are you looking at then why'd you end up
backing out well well I waited so we
like are you done with your story I
don't want to start my
you're done cuz you just talked about
how like you wanted to be a soldier and
then you didn't and then you talked
about your like binoculars and stuff
like what did you you said you want to
do that you left for right the very end
before yours was join like now that
you're your age now and you look back
when you're a kid I'm sure you're pretty
similar to me when I was a kid we're
like really yeah we're the same person
except I'm Korean we know yeah yeah do
you think you like would you are you
happy with how things are horrible
settings you yeah like I I am very very
happy creating awesome stuff with
awesome people and learning so much and
having the ability to learn so much and
like you know yeah yeah but I mean I'm
still learning it like that's my thing I
always want to learn always always
always always always want to learn and
be challenged like forever Sam oh yeah
because there's always that idea that
you know you took one path here life
which is funny that you mentioned the
whole multi-dimensional thing because I
always wonder you know if I take in a
different path in my life what I could
have been and what could out what I
could have done and answer your question
they go um I was really young I wanted
to be a fighter pilot do you do we do
yeah I know jet I want to be a fighter
pilot more than anything he's a little
kid and then I realized as I got older I
like looked into how difficult it is to
be a fighter pilot and also just not
only how difficult the training is like
how selective it is and also just
they're not I wanted to be a fighter
pilot for the wrong reason it's because
I wanted to be a badass I want to be
looked up to and I wanted a pilot this
awesome jet and getting in dogfights
that doesn't happen wait what's wrong
with that that's not a realistic thing a
fighter pilot does yeah and I was like
okay well I'm glamourizing it and it's
not really that so then I moved on and I
eventually I wanted to be an FBI agent
because my cousin was applying for FBI
when I was younger and I like would
watch him to his training and stuff and
he would teach me and he
take me shooting and all that stuff like
that so I really looked up to my cousin
a lot he was like my hero when I was a
young kid he's the reason I grew my hair
out longer because he had longer hair he
was super long wasn't it
well he had hair that was like down to
his chin this was like 90s so it was
like really in style that sure but you
know I looked up to him a lot and I
looked into what it takes to be FBI and
that led to me realizing that if you
want to be FBI the most realistic is
you're a cop and then you possibly make
detective or you have ex-military
background those are the main routes you
have to take to become FBI and then I
was okay well if I want to do that my
best route is to become military so then
I wanted it to be Ranger I really want
to be a Special Forces so I would apply
for Marines and then go from Marine to
Ranger and that was my goal when I was a
kid so I trained and like read up on
like a Ranger handbook and out of like
use guns and all that and I would do all
the sort of training I was really young
like middle school ish around then and
then eventually I realized like to be a
ranger because I had friends who are
ex-military and like my friends older
brothers and like parents were you've
learned that that kind of job the kind
of commitment it takes to be Special
Forces wallet is like glamorous as your
kid it's like a career job it's a life
career job you can't be Special Forces
and then like dabble okay we have
special force you have to be full
Special Forces and I was like do I want
to commit my entire life do like four
years of service to not even possibly
make Special Forces possibly die along
the way and would that would I be happy
with that and I ended up not doing it
because I just felt like I was doing for
the wrong reasons I felt like it wasn't
because I really really wanted to serve
those more I was doing it as a route to
get me to where I wanted to be which is
like either like a detective or FBI
agent or something like that so you know
that was my original goal which is why I
was like so obsessed with you know
police and guns and stuff also like when
I was a very young kid the first person
every time I shoot a gun in elementary
was a guy who went to my church at the
time and he was a sheriff and I really
looked up to him because he was like a
really cool guy I was in Georgia and he
taught me how to shoot he taught me how
to clean a Glock and he's the first
person let me hold an m16 and I had a
lot of respect for him so I really want
to be a cop / detective when I grow
didn't really happen but back to your
multi-dimensional thing I always thought
what if I did pursue that what if I did
pursue being a cop and then I eventually
made detective and I worked homicide and
I ended up catching some serial killer
or some pedophile or something and due
to that these other people didn't get
hurt or killed and I think about that a
lot I'm like you know I'm sitting here
making Internet videos and playing video
games was just fun and all but I feel
like I could possibly have had a much
bigger impact or at least more
meaningful in different ways and I
wonder about that
hmm yeah yeah before I went off to
college my grandma pulled me aside and
she was like you know so you have an
education and you know you're fairly
bright why aren't you becoming like a
doctor and she didn't mean that like the
generic why aren't you a doctor but like
you know like why didn't you do that I'm
like the Asian way yeah it's like what
it was in like I said he's like so what
are you going to do to help the world
and I'm like ah man being put on the
spot by my grandma right now I was like
well I mean and I already been doing
movies for like four years by this point
not movies but you know videos or
whatever so I was pretty clearly set on
that path and she knew it
and like so she really challenged me all
of a sudden right then and there to be
like why are you making videos like what
are you going to do like it's like you
can make videos but what are you going
to do to make up for the fact that
you're not going out there and being a
doctor or any other you know engineer or
any other person is going to bring to
society like what are you going to bring
to society doing what you're doing and
think about that
so that's stuck with me I think that's
part of why we've done so many tutorials
on our channel you know gonna help other
people yeah yeah cuz I mean I'm sure I
know you and you
and like most people probably listening
to this like you've learned so much by
just watching interest tutorials that
you would never have learned and my
entire internet career is based off of
mostly tutorials you know like I didn't
even finish my college me neither yeah
yeah I always knew that I wanted to do
something artistic I didn't quite know
what that was saying but I picked up a
guitar the first time when I was about
11 10 or 11 years old and I just fell in
love with it and I played guitar every
day for years for years and years and
years I did bands in college and high
school and we were in a band
mm-hmm there's so I was always into that
and I always knew like that was my I
always enjoyed that I was wanted to do
it I was wanted and then kind of through
that you know you introduced you and Sam
basically introduced me to the video
world and I and I thought well this is
fun too so I guess I always that was the
one thing to go back to the original
question like what's changed and what's
the same that's been the same mmm I've
always knew I've always known that and I
didn't know if it was gonna be a hobby
of mine or an actual career of mine but
I always knew like I wouldn't have
really been happy if I hadn't done
anything artistic and then you know
having the obviously the opportunity to
have that as a career is like super
rewarding I think so I've never asked
myself the question of like what like
he's not in this particular you know job
like what we're doing for the world
because I feel like it's it's there and
it's and it's and it's it is kind of a
cheesy answer to say like well you
people watch your stuff or they listen
to it or they whatever and they you know
gives them something each day but that
is there's more I think to be said for
that then then I think we're really
taking because think about when you're
thinking about when you were in high
school and how you
into certain bands or certain for me it
was bands cuz I was into music and it
was like that okay I'm gonna define my
personality by listen to this man this
man okay and anyone who listens to this
man this man this man not friends with
him I think that was that it was so
culturally important to define myself
through those things that I've made it
part of who I was and obviously as I got
older I realized how ridiculous that is
and how like you can appreciate all
kinds of different forms of art but yeah
that was and in a way I hope that some
of the stuff we make at least like gives
people a little bit of that seems to I
do it for a much more selfish reason
what's that well like I was saying like
I used to want to be a detective and a
soldier and fighter pilot I realized at
a young age I was like you know what I
want to do so many different things and
there's no way for me to actually do any
of those things and also do another
thing so I was like you know what being
actor or making movies you can do all of
those things you can still sleep in your
bed at night and it was a way of me to
be able to like tap into these things
that I'm passionate about I really like
and be able to do them but also be able
to do other things at the same time it's
the ultimate hack that's what my dad
told me he was like you know to join the
military
again you can dude you're running around
blowing up stuff in the field next door
like that explosion went over the
treetops yeah you just do that probably
trying to look out for your safety yeah
I mean it's it's a way of that's why I
think being an actor is like one of the
best jobs ever
and it's also yeah obviously it's one of
the hardest cuz there to be super
talented but to be able to live all
these different lives it's like being a
multi-dimensional being and getting paid
for it speaking of acting by the way
guys if you are at all interested in
working with actors you should consider
today's sponsor and now it's time for me
to tell you about today's beautiful
wonderful sponsor
story box now if
haven't been listening to the other
episodes story blocks is your one-stop
shop for all your stock video needs it's
a Members Only site that once you have
membership gives you access to 4k studio
quality stock footage it gives you
b-roll it gives you motion graphics it
gives you After Effects templates
they've got a whole bundle of different
things if you're a filmmaker or video
editor and you're looking for the little
snippets here and there to tie together
your scenes and to tie together your
piece consider story blocks it's a lot
cheaper and easier than trying to buy
stock footage as one offs as you come
across problems and your edits it's a
lot more efficient this way and of
course well you are a member you can
download as much as you want it's all
royalty-free so you don't have to worry
about how you're using it or when you're
using it or where you're using it and of
course everything you use well you are a
member
remains in place and effective after or
if you decide to cancel your membership
so they're one of the best in the
business guys definitely consider them
go to story box comm slash cord or cast
to get started and like I said in the
last episode you won't be disappointed
if you do so again that's story box comm
slash corridor cast check them out now
back to the episode and now that you
know that go ahead and get some of that
stock footage for yourself and put it in
front of or behind your next actor the
question yet of what's change and what's
the same so let's hear it
let's change what's the same what I was
actually like pose a discussion question
of like what is something that did stick
with you I'm high school and go forward
but alright let's jam yeah so there's
been a gamble that I took on my life
when I was and I don't mean like
revolver like with only one bullet
I mean more in the sense that like I
start doing video work like visual
effects when I was 14 years old or so
maybe like slightly before that and
there's a sense of like okay this is
super cool if I stick with it now by the
time I hit college I'll have five years
under my belt already everybody else
would be just starting now five years
and it's worth mentioning that like so
in seventh grade eighth grade um no
ninth grade it's 2000 1999 to 2000 ninth
grade yeah
ninth grade is when the first digital
video cameras came out the first iMovie
came out first Final Cut Pro came out
the first IMAX came out before that like
I was literally doing a video course
whereas VHS to VHS editing where you
queue up the one VHS and you put onto
the other one and in the very first
digital video like programs became
accessible to the person who did wasn't
wasn't in Hollywood you know the first
any leaves they called them not near
editors we're coming came out when I was
in eighth grade media 100 was the first
one Ellie's yeah
and so to me to me like I would I was
actually really into special effects and
pyrotechnics
I loved fire I still love fire I think
it's very beautiful and I I've missed
the practical pyrotechnics they had back
in the day like the people that were
doing
backdraft like what they did with fire
in that movie is like nobody else does
that these days it's a lost art there's
some good pyrotechnics out there but
anyways I digress
so there was this kind of like mental
commitment where it's like I really like
this and if I commit to it and I stick
with it like I'm going to have a leg up
when I hit college and I stick with it
then I'm gonna have a real leg up with
it when I'm coming out of college if I
still stick with it then that I'm gonna
be able to crush it when I hit the job
market so it was kind of like at the
expense of other things I went home and
I worked on videos I did
visual effects I did tutorials and I was
very very active in it and that's
actually around the same time that same
when I started hanging out and he kind
of did the same thing and so I was
really lucky that had another guy
that committed to it like I did so you
know going once again when we hit
college boom he and I were at the top of
our game there was no one else doing
visual effects like we were doing and
there's no one else that even really
knew how to process digital video to the
extent that we were processing it to
make it look better than it was because
these were you know by today's standards
really junky cameras and then coming out
of college we we got a production gig
doing directing movie you know there's
only like a 40,000 dollar budget but we
got that because we knew how to make
this work and there's no one else like
us coming out of college at that time
that could do that kind of stuff so this
gambit paid off in that you know it got
me from being in rural Minnesota because
for all intensive purposes Stillwater is
kind of rural still out to Los Angeles
and I was able to make that jump from
being some guy in the Midwest to being
here in the city like making movies and
meeting people in Hollywood and all that
kind of stuff any of your hard that you
know kind of jumping in with both feet
when I was 14 years old but from then to
now what I've kind of realized is that
like just like you with glamorizing or
jet fighters like glamorizing film
directors it's not what I thought it was
when I was 14 years old you know but
something odd happened in that process
is that because I was just doing it
anyways I kind of ended up making what I
wanted to be in my mind like that
glamorous vision I had of directing
films I wasn't getting that from you
know quote-unquote Hollywood but I was
getting it just doing it myself and
doing it the way I wanted to do it um so
you know Here I am now in like question
I'm asking myself and I was like do I
wanna make movies like Here I am having
run a youtube channel now if like nine
years I haven't really made any movies I
mean sync rush like those are almost
movies but not really movies you know
but what we've what we're doing now is
like in a way I think so much more
fulfilling um a film would be really
cool but the film would have to be made
like a movie like a movie would be made
in like the mid 90s which is say like a
lot of creative freedom a lot of trust
some really cool experiments and really
cool people around you and just what I
see movies these days the
business has become so confined and so
strict that that idea of enjoying your
art is gone like it's completely gone
unless you're shooting something really
small budget where the money doesn't
matter that much like that no one's
gonna let you have fun on a set that's a
200 million dollar set like every single
second of the day is budgeted and
accounted for and you are just there to
be the lead Foreman on a construction
job building that movie and that's like
the opposite of what I want to do so
yeah you know like to answer your
question like I'm really happy making
the art I'm making now I'm actually I'm
even more happy that my life is not the
same thing every day and to me it's
almost the most important thing I get to
have experience is the same thing like
you were saying 'die like we're not
actors per se but we're getting all the
benefits yeah without the the BS we
could do what we want to do and yeah and
do it on our own accord and we get to
decide what it that is yeah which is
great yeah I think yeah and that's the
American dream really yeah I think that
we probably will end up making I don't
know if they'll be called movies or what
if they'll be distributed like movies I
think we'll probably end up doing some
long-form narrative stuff born into the
future but it's gonna be like you said
it's gonna be an artistic endeavor and
not a construction project right and I'm
having so much fun like doing what we're
doing right now that I'm not even
worried about it you know I'm just like
what what's the next cool little thing
that we can make here what's the next
like how can we blow people's minds on
another video how can we turn this thing
that's really what is really like the
stuff that you guys have been doing with
effects lately it's just it's really
this high concept art form but the fun
of it is turning it around and making it
this kind of ridiculous form of
entertainment at the same time and like
that no one's doing that
well we're in that we're down we're like
we were talking about this earlier today
we're like we ended up in YouTube
because we were aiming for movies and
missed there's not really anyone else on
YouTube that did that like there's a
couple but most of those channels are
gone by this point yeah I mean I feel
like everyone at this table we're we
were all aiming for movies and then we
missed and we can light it on YouTube
yeah but let's let what it's led to now
is that we have this skill set of that's
very informed by Hollywood and Hollywood
movies and you know traditional film and
we're the ones who have brought that
skill set over to YouTube and now we're
getting to show people like
understanding how YouTube works and
being able to present a story on YouTube
and being able to be a personality in
front of the camera and being able to
express it verbally to everybody we're
able to do all that with the YouTube
sensibilities in the YouTube skill set
but we're also then able to bring all
this knowledge and experience from this
other world over and I I can't really
point to like big Hollywood movies that
I did effects on it effects on Britney
Murphy's last movie before she died but
you know that's it that was like my last
gig and that was like 10 years ago right
yeah it's like what you're saying where
you don't really you really know where
you're gonna land but early on you knew
you're like if I do this and I really
work hard at it I'm gonna excel at the
next thing and you know as filmmakers
making films it's a lot more challenging
than making YouTube videos so we trained
ourselves to make films so that when we
came to YouTube we're like oh this is
easy that's that's it so like we were so
far ahead of the game and in terms of
like knowing what looks good what sounds
good
how to tell a story what are what are
good characters like what's important
for a good video and that's what clearly
you know led us to being successful or
like in a big way thing like okay like
having that experience and having those
skill sets that most people didn't have
like most people on YouTube like here's
a web camera I'm gonna talking to it and
like that was it so that's kind of I
think really important and actually kind
of segues me into a question I had for
you guys if you when you guys are young
and let's say
if you could go back into high school
and meet your high school self what you
tell that person that isn't financial
advice so you know stop like yeah number
no stop no it's not what - but what
would you tell that person and at same
time what do you think that person would
say or how do you think that person
would feel if they could look into the
full into the future let's say you're
like 15 and they look at you now did you
do you think you would ever seen
yourself doing what you're doing and
yeah how does that make you feel I think
it was a lot clean you wanna go first
[Music]
you can sit the second question first
that easier question okay so like what
would I tell myself and then what would
myself say yeah like what do you what do
you think yourself would be like like
imagine if your 15 year old stuff come
into the future and see you now like
what do you think he would say to you
and then vice versa probably look at the
one will be like sweet dude probably
like it's that one glimpse of glimpse of
time when you're on fire oh my god yeah
geez man I don't know um like I am
basically the same person I was when I
was in high school just a little smarter
and with write a few more books I guess
and you know I followed the exact path
that I wanted to do when I was in high
school which was create really cool
stuff I still really want to do a movie
that's for sure definitely want to do a
movie because going back to being
challenged I want to be challenged
constantly and you like you said movies
a big challenge that's something that I
would have a lot of fun doing but man um
yeah what would you say to yourself was
a kid man if there is something there
might not be anything you might if you
just be like just keep doing what you're
doing kid you'll make it eventually um
man dude like I don't know like it's not
an easy question it's not um
maybe maybe research research taxes a
little bit so that he attacks a dude I
like taxes have brought me so much pain
an English man like I didn't know that's
a good thing I don't know how to do him
and I was 1099 getting like I remember
that production like budgets for shorts
for games and I'm like oh yeah you made
all this money what it's like no no no I
didn't make that money yeah that was
just what was the budget and like I
didn't know that you had the right stuff
off I didn't know what you could write
off I didn't know any of this stuff and
I've been like dude I'm I was on the
phone with the tax guy today today this
very day man and it's just like the IRS
it hits me like yo you owe more money
because you under whatever you know and
then it's like oh well I'm never got
money back
that's a good tip for all the young
listeners dude like taxes and taxes and
I probably would have liked when I came
out here I did martial arts for like ten
years
mmm and I came out here and I started I
picked up freerunning and then I like
snapped my ankle so you'd be like hey
learn taxes don't learn freerunning and
then I realized that doing a backflip is
not worth it like totally not like get
into yoga and keep doing martial arts
like that's those are probably whatever
told myself but yeah as far as a
Christian good don't do backflips oh oh
oh my god dude
another thing that I would've told
myself nothing I told myself I loved
video games and I love a challenge even
again like you were talking about
wherever you put in the video game
harder it is better against Mario Kart I
would have learned how to play that game
with input with input lag so I would
have been able to oh yes
sweep the competition when I was already
sweet house it tell the story from the
beginning
okay so Disney XD Disney was putting on
a sweet happen in Mario Kart tournament
at the YouTube space
I filled Jimmy Wong's shoes he was like
take my place I'm traveling he's like
yeah yeah oh yeah two cars and jetski
and like he's like fill my shoes this
Mario Kart turn you're the only one like
do you have to take me and Jimmy would
connect yeah on Mario Kart dude for
years and so yeah went to the tube space
put on this whole thing and Jimmy was
like dude there's $20,000 $20,000 grand
prize for the first place I was like
Jimmy I got it I'm gonna win like I've
got it a hundred percent yeah I will not
let you down
and so I go there just like it's throw
anything at me dude we're playing we're
playing with Leamas not a problem like
easy dude easy all adapt 200cc I trained
for that knocked it out friggin three
stars everything pretty limbs crushed it
which console we it was a we yeah it was
a week did we you and and then it gets
to the point where like we're in the
green room and there oh I'm sorry I was
giving up skip ahead right so
preliminaries across the preliminaries
huh then next up is how bad did you
crush it for there it was sweep dude it
was like all this dirt around and I had
this mop and I'll just mop yeah it was
bad I laughs some people for sure
oh jeez it was like a bunch of like
influencers yeah yeah so then and then
it comes time for the semi-finals and
during the semi-finals this like it like
a like a play
like a virus dude it rolls in and it
gets worse and worse this input lag this
input delay like when I hit right when I
hit right 2 seconds later my cart goes
right what I'm like this is how I'm
gonna lose this match like I had had it
how did that happen like they were
hooked because they were like
live-streaming it right so they were
hooking it in through one thing hooking
in through another hooking it up to the
receiver to the TV that back finally
some itv up on the stage and like a
little tiny thing and I'm just like
racing like that despite the input lag I
managed to get through the semi-finals
mm-hmm they're like dude I'm like you
guys gotta fix this this is this is
uncalled for so they're like right look
the finals they are in two hours we're
gonna work on this guys go to the green
room have some snacks chill we're gonna
take care of this everyone's gonna start
coming here in about 30 minutes there's
live crowd like legit so I go back in
the green room and I'm like everyone
let's go right now
everyone's training yeah dude first
place first place first place first
place they were shaking my hand they
said good game dude you got it like man
and I was feeling come back you're like
we fixed the input lag yes yes fix the
input lag fantastic the freaking crowd
is all in there's like 200 people
everyone's like cheering and there's
like sweeping cameras and everything and
like confetti and crap and food on this
side skewers and dips and everything
like this will be a quick story
[Music]
I was that that Worchester sauce so it's
no problem dude
so I go up and right before like when I
go up on stage get the remote and I get
the headset right before the match
starts this tech comes up and he's like
shake and he's got freaking pit sweats
and he's like guys its back and I'm like
oh my god dude oh my god of course it
was it back for everyone or just
everybody dude is back for everybody
okay
freakin lost weight so what am i meeting
everybody without him he'll like and
then everyone had input like how did you
yeah what Stan was like being like a
Mario Cart shark and was like oh I'm
losing how they actually trained no I
know no I just like you can ask Eli when
I start to like when I start to slip
dude it gets bad I don't know hard I
tilt super hard it goes it goes I'm like
oh made a mistake like Oh made a mistake
it's done Ronda Rousey style that's
that's really rough layout well we I
complained I was like oh I mean like the
last lap last lap dude forget moo moo
Meadows I don't know I guess I got I got
I got second place oh I got second place
okay yeah that sucks so yeah first place
$20,000 say please interesting so yeah I
complained and got like 1500 bucks and
then they gave you 15 or bucks for
complaining second and third place got
1500 bucks
oh so didn't get zero dollars no but do
not good at 20k consolation prize yeah
he actually gave me please you gotta
constantly give me $1,500 for playing a
video
yeah that's no very small brandy who
else's won $20,000 playing Mario Kart I
could have an the only guy I couldn't
the guy dude you could have been who
wants true some freaking dude I don't
know should have another tournament not
for $20,000 in one cent okay here's the
thing
if anyone can be me Mario Kart well
there's probably people in Japan I'm
ready for challenge that's that's you
there's nothing gonna be you know that's
Johnny he challenged me to match I've
beat him all four times I was like look
if you beat me in one of these matches I
will do something really embarrassing
basically like walk across VidCon and
like walk across like the main center of
VidCon going like and I was like but if
I beat you all four times you have to do
that yeah Johnny Bosworth man that's
what I told myself all right
Wow Wow yeah everythink you have to
answer the same question I'm just right
here in clinch shadow tell yourself what
would you tell yourself you can't even
have to take 15 minutes and tell the
whole story about Disney XD about two
cars one jet ski Jimmy Wang so I'm just
still riding high on Clinton story about
Mario Kart I yeah my goal is to make my
wish list my shopping cart that's what
you tell yourself that's my goal I'm
glad you remembered know he called him
something well you're holding two cars
in jet ski cause he won that to one of
them because he already had a car we had
so many cars like he was getting taxed
on some one car and then he
on prices right he won a car and a
jetski so we'll be like dude this guy's
so rich man like we're gonna keep that
jet ski because he listened like
downtown is the rocketjump studios old
merchant self he's so rich it was yeah
that was the funniest part dude oh man
so good wow those are good times I know
I guess I ready to go talk to high
school Nico I'd say you're on the right
path you're all set it's like the
initial variables that I came up with
for my like life for myself worked out
keep on them it's good basically
everything I wanted to do in high school
I've done so I'm good and I think of
high school me saw me now you bike dude
you got a VR headset what's like what's
having a life like yeah yeah do you play
video games got a one you have a wife
that you play video games with that's
well sorry young Nico she only plays
mario kart with me nothing
destroy her in Mario Kart no because
[Laughter]
there yeah
how are you generator man I've been
thinking about this since you brought it
up so I probably have a better answer so
I've had more time to think about it I
tell myself I said Jake young man you
little [ __ ]
don't be afraid of don't be afraid of
yourself this is probably what I'd tell
myself because there there's so much
like with all this I was doing all this
thinking you know I was really good at
track obviously that got me through
college and stuff and that was great
that set me up for a lifetime of just
establishing a work ethic and like going
back for the Hall of Fame induction
I am yeah I'm going back to the I'm
going back in September for the st.
croix Valley Athletic Association Hall
of Fame induction
Wow that's awesome yeah it's pretty cool
they inducted my brother a few years ago
and now they get me so I'm always second
that stuff which is no surprise but I'm
honored to do it and so I'd say hey keep
doing track that's great it set me up
for and this is what more what I'm gonna
say in the acceptance speech but
basically it set me up for a lifetime of
not being afraid of just doing the work
to get something like because distance
running oh my god it's the worst but I
still do it today I still do it for
training I still do it for health but
what it does is it it just like hardens
in your mind like this ability to be
like no I'm just gonna cut through you
know I'm just like this needs to get
done I need to grind it out I need to do
it absolutely dude it gave you
discipline man right exactly it gives
you discipline and without that I
probably I don't know what I would be
I'd probably be like riding with the
Mongols or something that's that's
probably what I would be doing I'm not
even kidding and then and then also I'd
tell myself don't be afraid of yourself
you know you like in high school there's
all these things about you know who you
hang out with and what you do and how
these things are gonna define you one
day and segments all that's [ __ ]
like just be yourself and learn the
things that you find inspirational and
go after them and utilize that work
ethic that you're learning from sport to
apply to the rest of your life and
you'll be fine
and it took me about until college to
figure that out but I'm glad I figured
it out then yeah that's so important man
just hard work discipline and and
persistence well that's what that's what
somebody was on Joe Rogan talking about
that the other day and about what's his
name um Jaco wall Nick or something he's
a he's a he's an ex-military guy and his
whole philosophy is discipline equals
freedom and ciborium guy yeah he's the
foreign guy
like way too intense about it like the
the thing that the point that he was
making the point that Rogan was making
was like this is freeing to this guy
because he doesn't need to worry about
what he's gonna be doing at 4:00 a.m.
the next day he just knows he's gonna be
doing doing this workout or whatever you
know whatever his version of that
discipline is and so sometimes I take on
that a little bit too and I'm like you
know no I'm just gonna do this because I
got to do it and it's so good dude such
like such a good characteristic to have
it's like just discipline man it's so
good yeah all right
well Dee that was a good did you answer
that deed oh yeah depose it buddy you
didn't um I'll make it quick cuz this is
already going all along ah it's cool I I
mean well first of all if my 15 year old
self could flash forward and see myself
getting paid to play video games and
airsoft with my friends and getting to
film movies and riding motorcycles and
living in Los Angeles and going to
parties and all this stuff he'd be like
holy [ __ ] this is awesome
ah but I will say that a lot of it has
to do with if I could go back and talk
to myself and say something cuz like
he'd be tall stocky but oh man
everything looks great you know like
that looks super fun and you know you're
doing everything that I love and that
one that is true I think it's really
really important to understand that the
skills you learn like Niko saying early
on in life they will really really
impact what you do in the future not be
not just on like how passionate you are
about it but like just the experience
and the yeah how much you have done it
and how good you are at it will affect
your later life tremendously so really
focusing on something and knowing early
on what you want to do is really
important even if that's not where you
end up having a goal and something to
focus on like I want to do filmmaking
and then you know going for that even if
you don't end up there that pass will
lead you to a way of finding out what
you really do want to do want to really
make you happy because I know a lot of
people struggle with their like I don't
know what I want to do I don't know what
I want to be and I think figuring that
out
early is really key because as you get
older it gets a lot harder to do so
finding something you're really
passionate about and really working hard
at it and you know eventually if you're
smart and you have a little bit of luck
on your side you'll be able to turn that
into a career and into a way of making a
living and that my friends is the
American dream yeah
and also if you are one of those people
out there who doesn't know what you want
to do and with each passing day these
advice becomes more and more real in
your head and more and more mounting and
you realize with each passing day the
more you don't know what you want to do
a detriment to another day into the
future also consider this you may become
passionate about what you're currently
doing and there are a lot of people out
there and myself included like I I have
become a lot more passionate for this as
the more and more that I've done it
mm-hmm I obviously loved it when we
first started out and it was it was
great it was a totally different time it
was but I like there's a lot of people
out there that are very successful at
whatever it is that they do and they've
found over time that they've become
passionate about that and sort of
learned to love it rather than loved it
and then gotten into it oh yeah I mean
if if you're good at something you're
gonna enjoy it if you're better than 98%
of the population at something you're
gonna love doing it it's like can you
play a video game you're really good at
it yeah you're gonna have a good time if
you're suck at it probably I can have a
very good time same thing with your
career like if you're crushing it like
same thing like you're saying like
you've been doing this for a long time
and you found a love for it's probably
cuz you've gotten a lot better at it and
you feel better about doing it you know
you're doing a good job and that is
rewarding itself yeah and that yeah that
definitely applies to career
and just you know just work hard to be
good at what you are just if you're
gonna do something be the top percentile
of the people who do that thing yeah
that's about it that's a good podcast
yeah I'm glad we talked about this
instead of the news or three for the day
yeah but next time you might talk about
the news again so don't get any crazy
ideas thinking that we're just gonna be
spewing our hearts to you guys every
time we come on this show yeah I just a
little shout out to everybody listening
to this podcast and watching this on
YouTube you know on one channel we have
a show that gets two million views and
here it is just us and you a couple
thousand listeners viewers yeah it's
nice about 40,000 people really yeah
across YouTube and the audio only yeah
it's nice having like a close-knit
community that we can talk to so thank
you for listening and we do read the
comments yes we do actually I really
enjoy reading the comments I keep
looking for something to call me out for
I could dumb philosophy yeah but hasn't
happened actually it's been really cool
like people come back with a great
responses and like cool discussion
points and great questions and like it
just really needs seeing how many other
fascinating and interesting people are
out there and that they listen to us and
contribute back it makes it a
conversation so thanks everybody I
appreciate it till next time so long see
you guys